une place de choix dans l'allée centrale
réservée en chine au personnage traité
avec le plus grand respect norman
bethune est glorifié dans ce cimetière
militaire ou de hauts gradés chinois
n'ont droit qu'à une tombe
once tél c'est le plus bel endroit du
village l'ancien résident de ce coin
pauvre et isolée de kobe dans le centre
du pays
il ajoute c'est une grande fierté pour
nous d'avoir son mémorial
ici le docteur béthune est un ami de la
nation il a exercé ici dans les
montagnes environnantes sur le front
norman bethune avait mis sur pied des
unités médicales mobiles
sa philosophie les médecins doivent se
rendre jusqu'au patient jusqu'au soldats
et pas l'inversé
le médecin originaire de l'ontario était
arrivé en chine en janvier 1938
fort de son expertise en chirurgie
thoracique de son expérience des
champs-de-bataille acquise quelques
années plus tôt durant la guerre civile
en espagne et il était motivé par le
désir d'aider les troupes communistes de
mao tsé-toung à leur combat contre
l'envahisseur japonais
il a tout laissé derrière lui une belle
position dans la société de bons revenus
pour servir dans des conditions
difficiles c'est mieux cette spécialiste
de norman bethune il manger la même
chose que les combattants du mil des
pommes de terre il dormait sous le même
toit que nous soldats de la grille à
éclairées par des lampes à l'huile
ce qui est extraordinaire à mes yeux si
qu'il était aussi un inventeur
s'adaptant aux conditions nous avons vu
une de ses inventions qu'il avait
baptisé la clinique ambulante une ce
pont marco polo il s'agit de cette table
d'opération conçu pour être installé sur
un cheval
elle servait aussi aux transports
d'instruments norman bethune a également
formé du personnel médical
il a rédigé des manuels d'instruction
conseiller médical de la viiie armée de
terre de mao
le canadien ne s'est pas ménagé il a
vieilli prématurément un exploit retient
particulièrement l'attention
il a travaillé sans arrêt pendant plus
de soixante-dix heures
il a ainsi sauvé plus de 100 blessés il
a même fêté ses 49 ans sur le front il
se qualifiait d' un vieux soldat il
était content d'avoir passé et si son
anniversaire
ça aura été le dernier anniversaire de
norman bethune en novembre 1939 et
contracte une infection du sang après
avoir effectué une opération à mains
nues malgré une coupure au doigt mais ne
restait plus de gland il meurt de cette
septicémie autres de médicaments et
chinois célèbrent nommé tune pour son
altruisme pour son courage au premier
chef
mao dont l'hymne aux sons graves est ici
dans la pierre un étranger sans penser à
son propre bien m prend la libération du
peuple chinois comme sa propre mission
c'est l'esprit de l'internationalisme
c'est l'esprit du communisme c'est
l'esprit que tout un chacun doit
apprendre pour la cause de la révolution
chinoise dans les manuels scolaires en
chine
on retrouve encore l'hommage de mao à
norman bethune ce médecin érigée en
symbole des relations sino-canadiennes
des relations qui ont déjà connu des
jours meilleurs
ici annick bureaud radio-canada dans la
baie